for the last few weeks Michael Gove has
had his sights set on a promising future
I can confirm that I will be putting my
name forward to be prime minister of
this country but it is his past that's
getting attention right now mr. groves
cocaine admission comes right in the
middle of his bid for the Tory
leadership mr. Gough told the Daily Mail
I took drugs on several occasions at
social events more than 20 years ago at
the time I was a young journalist it was
a mistake
I look back and think I wish I hadn't
done that members of the Conservative
Party very much like people you'll often
meet down the pub or similar they'll
have had different experiences in their
own lives and but they're making a
judgment on who they think can take the
country through leaving the European
Union and the years ahead
please welcome Jeremy Corbyn and if you
expected the leader of the Opposition to
use mr. gobs drug-using admission
against him to question his suitability
as leader that simply didn't happen I
think people should tell us what they've
done and move on in life but I'm I'm
concerned about Michael Gove past life
or behaviour to be honest Michael Gove
follows a long line of politicians
who've confessed to drug use former
leader of the House of Commons Andrea
led some is the latest to admit she
smoked cannabis at university but not
since Boris Johnson said he once snorted
cocaine but sneezed so he didn't
actually take it while former US
President Bill Clinton said he wants to
cannabis but didn't inhale and when
asked if he'd ever smoked marijuana the
former New York Mayor Michael Bloomberg
replied you bet I did and I enjoyed it
the question is of course amid all this
talk about taking drugs albeit 20 years
ago can it really affect mr. Gold's
chances of moving in to this place
it's confessing a sin enough or will the
grass roots of the Conservative Party
expect more their leader
Michael Prescott is a political
strategist the system is you know you've
got to get the votes of conservative MPs
and if you make it into the runoff two
people seek the votes of conservative
grassroots members now just imagine what
if and it is a what if what if the
runoff is between Boris Johnson and
Michael Gove Boris Johnson is already
previously admitted cocaine use so you
could imagine a runoff where you've got
two people who've confessed their drug
sins and the sins would cancel each
other out
in the race for the leadership mr. gobs
admission may become a mere talking
point perhaps proving that there's no
such thing as bad publicity McMartin Sky
News Westminster